sous la présence de mandature
l'endettement de la France a augmenté de
700 milliards vous savez qu'on va
bientôt franchir les 3000 milliards de
dettes cette dette est là progressé deux
fois plus qu'en Allemagne qui est
souvent le pays que l'on cite en
référence parce que c'est une économie
un pays proche des nôtres et donc
nous avons tendance à nous comparer la
comparaison est cruelle pour le pour la
France en 2017 il y a 12 ans nous avions
le même taux d'endettement que que
l'Allemagne et nous avons désormais 50%
de dettes supplémentaires donc vous
voyez que c'est une épée de Damoclès et
c'est une épée de Damoclès qui
pèse sur notre souveraineté c'est une
faute morale vis-à-vis des générations
futures et il faut entamer dès
maintenant la réduction des dépenses je
rappelle que ça n'en prend pas le chemin
puisque sur le budget 2023 nous allons
faire un nombre la France va faire un
endroit record de 270 milliards d'euros
que le service de la de des intérêts de
la dette approchent le budget de
l'Éducation nationale on va bientôt être
à 60 milliards donc on voit que la
situation est intenable et il faut de
toute urgence effectivement réduire
l'endettement de la France mais
malheureusement ça n'est pas la
politique qu'en tant mener le
gouvernement et le président de la
République